er fordert lag mit seiner 160000 euro
geldstrafe plus anzeigen kelly mit ihren
youtuber nerven zusammen wo jetzt gerade
des seit 48 stunden auf platz 1 der
deutschen youtube das video von acht
tonnen namens drogenschulden und
schwester video wiso mein leben die
hölle im heutigen video gibt es dazu
meinen statement mehr oder weniger dazu
begehen möchte ich erst mal sagen dass
ich selbst kein psychologe oder
therapeut oder ansatzweise kluger mensch
denn ich bin eigentlich recht einfach
nur dumm wie scheiße allerdings bin ich
selber hauptberuflich youtuber und kenne
zudem auch noch kelly und anton
persönlich und sollte dementsprechend
einfach so ein bisschen mehr jeden heute
anton hat hier sogar auf meiner
unterschriften wand nach oben
unterschrieben direkt unser angelika
merkel wieder cdu alter ich fange jetzt
mal vorne an und zwar woher kennen an
toll und ich uns überhaupt
die sache ist dass wir uns nie so
richtig kennengelernt haben dadurch dass
wir wirklich aufeinander zugegangen sind
und gesagt haben lasst uns zu sagen ein
video drehen wir sind beide youtube ich
weiß gar nicht ob das ist gelebt haben
und ich mache weil ich schon sehr sehr
sehr sehr lange youtube-videos also
schon seit über fünf jahren und damals
war die youtube szene wirklich noch viel
viel viel viel kleiner und intimer als
ist das ganze jetzt ist von daher haben
wir uns dahingehend halt einfach auf
messen treffen video der fcz ab und zu
gesehen zudem waren wir zusammen auf
einem adidas sie werden mit dem fc
bayern münchen damals sehr lange
unterhalten haben weil sie den
kompletten abend zusammen verbracht
waren danach noch in der bar und zudem
war er auch als wie bei dem video der
s-bahn waren wir alle zusammen auf einer
spotify partie wonach er halt auch noch
mit hier waren mit sony und marcel und
julia und so noch und dann haben wir ja
noch was getrunken und so also bis jetzt
keine typische youtube bekanntschaft von
mir von wegen hey wir kennen uns
gegenseitig haben uns abonniert und
haben wir ein paar videos von einander
gleich sondern haben auch schon in mir
leid was zusammen unternommen also das
erstmal zum verhältnis von anfang an
wir sind jetzt nicht so krass befreundet
dass wir uns jetzt jeden tag schreiben
würden und uns gegenseitig zum
geburtstag einladen würden und so weiter
und so fort aber wir sind halt so dass
wenn wir bei einem event zusammen sind
unterhalten uns halt auch extrem land
genau das gleiche verhältnis habe ich
eigentlich auch mit kelly m wir kennen
uns auch nur über youtube und machen
beide schon sehr lange youtube zudem
sind kelly und ich im gleichen
management und dementsprechend auch oft
bei den gleichen kampagnen zusammen aber
mit kelly ist es auch so eine
freundschaft dass wir setzen nicht jeden
tag schreiben hey wie war dein tag und
wir gehen zusammen ins fitnessstudio und
abends lag ihre uns gegenseitig die
fußnägel worte allerdings habt ihr
glaube ich so vom bin ja verstehen in
welcher beziehung nicht zu anton und zu
kelly - wie dort stehe montana black
habe ich gar keine beziehung habe ich
glaube ich sogar noch nie irgendwo
gesehen ich verfolgte auch nicht auf
youtube und so weiter und so fort also
das ist eine person die mir sehr fremd
ist ehrlich gesagt allerdings sollte zum
heutigen video auch gar nicht um kelly
oder monte gehen aber allgemein um
dieses thema youtube und was dahinter
steckt so stress vorher und das
versteuert beschreibt sich schon ganz
gut allerdings erstmal an die ganzen
leute die dieses video von anton dieses
eine stunde 14 minuten langen video
nicht gesehen haben hier eine kurze
zusammenfassung wurde mir wieder ging es
darum dass anton seinen abonnenten seine
bisherige youtube laufbahn erklärt hat
und gesagt hat wie einst zum anderen kam
da hat er hat gesagt dass er zu beginn
einfach aus jux und dollerei angefangen
hat sowie denke ich jeder youtuber
damals allerdings hat er halt nicht nur
gesagt ja ich habe damit angefangen mit
call of duty was glaube ich und hat man
dann meine leidenschaft für fußball
entdeckt habe ab und zu auch stadion
blogs gemacht die satellite ist nicht so
erklärt sondern hat gesagt was auch
dazwischen hinter den kulissen passiert
ist und das alte scheint einiges
passieren hat gesagt dass seine
schwester und der mann seiner schwester
sein schwager ihnen persönlich relativ
häufig um größere geldbeträge gebetet
haben und meinte anton wir haben hier
super geschäfte leihen uns mal geld du
kriegst auch save alles zurück ein mal
dürft ihr raten werden nichts zurück
bekommt ja anton er sagt also in seinem
video das er jahrelang immer seiner
resta und seinem schwager geldsummen
überwiesen hat gegeben hat für
irgendwelche projekte von denen er an
die bescheid muss arbeit inhalt vertraut
weil es familie war zudem bei auch noch
finanzieren in einigen verstrickten
lagen in denen er beispielsweise ein
riesiges haus in münchen ab bezahlen
musste
dann hat er auch noch irgendeinen
streaming haus mit freunden sondern
gaming haus was ja auch noch bezahlen
musste er hat allgemeine mal alle kosten
getragen die auch an vielen auch wenn es
nur kleinigkeiten waren wie essen
bestellen oder so das läppert sich
und diese ganze psychische belastung hat
ihnen dazu verleitet halt auch marihuana
zu konsumieren
also ab und zuträglich einen schmucken
und letztendlich war ja mehr oder
weniger so verzweifelt dass er ein video
online gestellt hat was er glaube ich
nie hätte online stellen dürfen
das hat glaube ich jeder mitbekommen
dass war diese schwester video wo er
seine schwester ziemlich komisch
dargestellt hat daraufhin hat anton
relativ viele hater erntet allerdings
meiner meinung nach auch zurecht bin ich
ganz ehrlich antwort nicht weiß wie es
dieses video er gerade sehen ich mag
dich unfassbar gern als menschen
darauf werde ich gleich noch mal kurz
eigentlichen allerdings war dieses video
und das heißt auch selbst ein kompletter
schuss in den ofen das video hatte zum
glück nach einiger zeit wieder gelöscht
und um euch ganz kurz zu sagen worum es
darin geht er hat seine schwester
vorgestellt auf youtube seinen
abonnenten allerdings nicht von wegen
hey wir setzen uns zusammen vor die
kamera was sein ursprünglicher plan war
von wegen wir beantworten ein paar
fragen erzählen was aus der
vergangenheit die ce er hatte seine
schwester in bad gefilmt wie sie sich um
zieht wie sie von hunden gefilmt wird
mit hohen schuhen wie wieder irgendein
kleidern und umläuft halten nackt
gefühlt und das ja das wirkte so von
wegen hey das ist meine schwester sie
ist ein objekt in dem video was anton
jetzt allerdings vor einigen tagen
hochgeladen hat hat er gesagt dass auch
er selbst gar nicht dieses video
hochladen wollte sondern dass eine idee
von seiner schwester und seinem schwager
war
die wollten dieses video zu drehen sein
schwager hat wohl auch viele
redaktionelle regisseure elemente dort
übernommen bei diesem video und daher
kam es eigentlich gar nicht wirklich von
ihm keiner seiner kollegen hatte die
weitsicht ihm zu sagen hey das könnte
eventuell ein bisschen halos treten alle
angesagt
aesculap als online gestellt das hatte
unfassbar viele dislike bin ich ganz
ehrlich zu recht hat er es so viele
dislike weil dieses video einfach gab
motive scheiße und die resonanz auf
dieses video hat anton dann natürlich
noch weiter in seinem loch geschmissen
und wo er schon finanziell drin war
durch den ganzen stress drin war mit den
ganzen gedanken von wegen ich muss auch
das abbezahlen ich habe hier noch die
schulden meine schwager und schwester
die schulden mir seit jahren geld dann
kann man noch dazu dass seine community
ihnen jetzt auch nicht mehr gefeiert hat
weil er halt dieses bescheuerte video
herausgebracht hat daraufhin dass anton
in ein loch gefallen hat sich zwar immer
noch ab und zu von dem geld was er
verdient hat irgendwelche versace marken
klamotten gekauft jetzt die ein mercedes
abend gegen liest über das wfp lieser
allerdings waren das alles nur einkäufe
und events die er besucht hat
beispielsweise bei irgendwelchen fußball
spielen um ihn selbst von der realität
abzulenken
dementsprechend hat er halt auch gras
konsumiert et cetera das war so grob die
zusammenfassung seines videos natürlich
ging jetzt meine zusammenfassung auch
über mehrere minuten allerdings hat er
natürlich auch in einen stunden video
eine menge menge infos verpackte die ich
jetzt hoffentlich mehr oder weniger grob
zusammengefasst habe für euch was ist
jetzt allerdings meine intention mit
diesem video hier gerade ich versuch es
ist herzlich wenig zu helfen ich habe
mir wirklich noch nie eine so langes
video also ich meine 74 minuten
ich habe mir noch nie so ein langes
video so konzentriert auf youtube
angeschaut ich habe ein kommentar das
video geschrieben und auch an sondern
auch auf whatsapp geschrieben allerdings
geht mir in diesem heutigen video
einfach nur darum weil ich halt in
letzter zeit gesehen habe wo vor einigen
wochen kelly hat dieses video auf
youtube nervenzusammenbruch wo sie
darüber berichtet dass sie den absoluten
leistungsdruck erlebt monte hausen
wieder raus von wegen er wusste nicht
wie man richtig versteuert und hat jetzt
ein mega viel scheiße und dreck am
stecken und jetzt kommt mit dem video an
und mein ja ich spiele zwar immer den
lustigen menschen hier habe ich das mal
die fassade fallen mega viel hinter den
kulissen gerade diese drei videos der
letzten wochen haben wir so ein bisschen
gezeigt dass immer mehr
juba jetzt nach den vielen jahren
checken was youtube wirklich mit einem
macht und was es bedeutet ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich bin sehr sehr sehr sehr froh
dass sich youtube angefangen habe als
ich noch zur schule gegangen bin weil
ich glaube wenn ich irgendwie schon
gearbeitet hätte und hätte durch youtube
mein erstes geld verdient ich hätte
gesehen
das ist mehr als ich mit meiner arbeit
verdiene ich mache mich direkt
selbstständig ich glaube das wäre nach
hinten los gegangen ich bin da wirklich
sehr froh darüber dass ich auch damals
nach meinem abi direkt gesagt habe hey
ich könnte zwar jetzt mit meinen youtube
einnahmen easy leben und müsste nicht
noch nebenbei arbeiten gehen aber ich
habe mir gesagt du fängst an zu
studieren und du ziehst das durch drei
jahre lang durch mein studium habe ich
unfassbar krass gelernt wie sehr man
youtube als beruf und als arbeitgeber
schätzen sollte also das war wirklich
wahnsinnig weiß auch ganz genau dass ich
damals in der uni saß morgens von 9 bis
13 uhr dann hasse ich nach hause nehmen
schnell ein video auf hatte sonnen
zeitfahren nacheinander gestrickt sind
neben einem video auf lammers hof gehen
danach wieder in die mitte lernen am
nächsten tag prakti kommen dann
irgendwie drei stunden schlaf damit ich
dann morgens um 5 uhr aufstehen kann und
noch ein video aus hass kann das ist ein
enormer leistungsdruck wie man sich
selbst zufügt aber ich bin ganz ehrlich
dadurch sieht man was youtube ist und
lernt es das ganze zu schätzen deswegen
eben zu kellys video dazu habe ich habe
bisher noch gar nichts gesagt und jeder
youtube hatte sicher damals dazu
geäußert und hat seine sicht der dinge
präsentiert ich konnte das video von
kelly nicht nachvollziehen
also ich weiß halt wie es ist wir hören
jeden tag zum praktikum muss morgens von
8 bis 18 uhr nach düsseldorf fahren dort
arbeiten und dann wieder zurück nach
köln fahren und dann noch in dem video
hinkriegen und noch soziale kontakte und
jim und oni nebenher note checkt man
wirklich erst mal wie dankbar man für
youtube zählen sollte und dass man sich
in keinster weise meiner meinem merkt
beschweren sollte das jetzt auch noch
kurze sache die ich habe ich vergessen
zu sagen als ich das video aufgenommen
habe deswegen ist im nachhinein man hat
ja auch bei youtube das privileg das man
keinen direkten arbeitgeber hat also man
erlebt jetzt nichts und leistung so von
wegen haye
diese arbeit muss fertig sein bis 18 uhr
an hat hier nur den leistungsdruck den
man sich selbst setzt man selbst ist der
leistungsdruck deswegen hätte falls du
das hier sehen sollte ist dass es
überhaupt nichts gegen dich persönlich
ich mag dich persönlich gerne bist einer
der nettesten menschen und der nettesten
youtuber in deutschland die ich wirklich
kenne aber dieses video
das kam wirklich ja auch bei vielen sehr
über von wegen verwöhnte göre ich weiß
was kelly mainz und ich hatte auch schon
zeiten wo ich in einer woche dreimal
nach berlin fliegen muss dazu in welchen
dreh ist und musste dann auch videos
machen und blabla aber es ist immer noch
schöner finde ich es gibt andere leute
die stehen in der zeit machen
fließbandarbeit youtube und
fließbandarbeit ihr wisst was ich meine
dahingehend auch noch mal eben zum monte
seinem 160000 euro strafe steuern
nachzahlen den cetera pp video
ich bin zum glück in der lage das mein
vater selber auch selbstständig ist und
er mir viel mit auf dem weg geben konnte
für meine selbständige karriere auf
youtube und das haupt dem was er
wirklich über die einnahmen beigebracht
hat die ich erziele über youtube oder
die ja jeder irgendwie erzielt ist luca
rechne nur mit der hälfte
wenn du einen deal hat für 200.000 euro
rechne mit 100000 euro
die nachher dir gehören also dieses
hauptwegen was er wirklich beigebracht
hat ist luca rechne immer mit der hälfte
da kann nichts passieren und seitdem
weiß ich wenn ich einen deal habe 200
haus ist vielleicht ein bisschen hoch
gegriffen
wenn ich jetzt in dieser habt für 80.000
euro dann weiß ich okay
80.000 euro ist eine menge aber ich
rechne dass ich 40.000 daran verdiene
was immer noch unfassbar viel ist
deswegen verstehe ich nicht warum leute
steuern hinterziehen
hey verdient doch immer noch voll und
mit leute meine ich jetzt zum beispiel
cristiano ronaldo oder uli hoeneß ob die
letzten paar millionen abgibt oder nicht
alter das bricht ja auch kein zacken aus
der krone dass ich da noch sagen möchte
ist leute denkt immer daran wenn ihr
irgendwelche einkünfte hat also ist
jetzt vielleicht auch ein
kleiner tipp für stalking deutsches
gesetz wenn ihr angehen der youtuber
seit und gerade wenn man lieber ist hat
man einnahmen aus allen möglichen
quellen von allen seiten als ich mein
erstes so ich habe meinen job
kooperation ich habe meine youtube
werbung da kommt jetzt seit neuestem
auch noch der epic games sofort support
to create dazu dann kommen noch
irgendwelche barta deals dazu dann
kommen noch twitch einkünfte dazu das
sind 6 1 aber quellen die mir jetzt
einfach so auf anhieb eingefallen sind
sechs seiten von denen geld kommt und
solche argumente von wegen hey das war
ein tritt spenden die muss ich nicht
versteuert das ist sorry motto das ist
einfach dumm unwissenheit schützt vor
strafe nicht das muss man halt immer
wieder so sagen und ich glaube der
größte tipp den man jemanden geben kam
es wirklich einfach zu sagen hey wenn du
was verdienst die hälfte der dir und den
recht deutschland das nur eben kurz
zudem montevideo und weil ich halt
wirklich sehr sehr viele youtuber sehen
gerade auch in deutschland die meines
erachtens nach sehr doll über ihren
maßstäben leben und dahin gehen wir
zurück der bogen zu vista basars video
was man über ihn auch immer raus gehört
hat ist er hat sich diese sache noch
teilweise geleistet sagt jetzt versace
klamotten oder ein mercedes amg einfach
weil es auch so vorgelebt wird
mittlerweile gibt es weniger youtuber in
deutschland die keinen mercedes
angefahren als welche die einen fahren
natürlich auch wegen dieses mercedes wir
piercings es ist soll leasingprogramm
von mercedes wo du halt krasse
konditionen hast finde ich absolut dumm
dass in anspruch zu nehmen sorry aber
das ist wirklich meine meinung und das
gerade ist ja auch mein statement wenn
jetzt ein anderer youtuber sagt hey ich
will unbedingt für zwei jahre mercedes
angefahren
denn dann falle ich das geld halt
einfach raus jeden monat und so denken
halt leider ziemlich viele youtuber in
deutschland ich kenne auch einige die
sich wirklich direkt als ihre ersten
einnahmen hatten direkt eine rolex
gekauft haben dann mercedes haben wir
ich denke hey wo sind dann die sitzt die
person die prioritäten ich glaube ich
schreibe gerade so ein bisschen vom
eigentlichen thema habe worum es mir
eigentlich ging bei den drei videos
zusammen die ich gesehen habe ist dass
youtube und das wird mittlerweile glaube
ich auch ziemlich vielen zuschauern von
euch klar dass youtube nicht einfach
zuckerschlecken ist
es ist sehr viel
stress der sich hier oben abspielt ich
habe totale respekt vor leuten die jeden
tag auf dem bau gehen und wirklich mit
ihrer kraft irgendwelche steine von a
nach b tragen und beispielsweise häuser
bauen
allerdings muss man da ganz ehrlich
sagen da gehst du auf der baustelle
damit geht's lose trick steine und dann
um 16 18 abgeschaltet und tricks keine
steine mehr und hass habe dann den abend
für dich frei und ist zu hause in
youtube job ist natürlich nicht so dass
so acht stunden dich an deinen pc setzt
und die ganze zeit arbeitet sondern ist
vorbei allerdings ist es halt so dass du
dich in meinem fall vier stunden am pc
setzt video aufnimmt schneidest und
danach gibt's aber weiter dann ich weiß
nicht wie oft ich dann mehr jetzt noch
beantwortet für 12 stunden oder
telefoniere bezüglich irgendwelcher
kooperationen oder dann auch einfach
diese tatsache dass man zwischendurch
instagram checkt aber nicht einfach
etwas andere gepostet haben sondern man
checkt hält seine sets und guckt hajo
wie läuft das neue video ich beantworte
ein paar kommentare interaktion mit den
zuschauern 3 pps sind viele weiche
faktoren wie überhaupt nicht mit diesen
harten faktoren von wegen er morgens
acht bis abends 16 uhr steine tragen zu
vergleichen sind
und das sieht man nicht und es kommen
nicht drüber in youtube videos von eurem
lieblings youtuber beispielsweise
allerdings sind youtuber an sich
wirklich häufig schauspieler in ihren
videos also ich bin ganz ehrlich ich
rede auch gerade viel lauter und viel
euphorischer ich sitze auch ganz anders
als wenn jetzt kumpels da will ich heute
sagen lass mal losgehen was essen ich
hoffe ihr wisst was ich meine und ich
hoffe ihr versteht was so ein bisschen
der sinn dieses videos hier ist ich
versuche ich mehr oder weniger drei
sachen auf dem weg zu geben erstens wenn
wir eine person seht auf youtube die
total happy ist und dann sagt ja
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen video
wir machen heute dies und das und das
kann den vorhang komplett anders
aussehen
deswegen das beispiel wissen gepaart mit
dem video was er vor ein paar tagen
hochgeladen hat in den letzten monaten
weiter regelmäßig videos hochgeladen und
ich hatte ja anton was ihr auch gesagt
hatte auf der spotify partie gesehen von
einem halben jahr war hier bei mir mit
in der wohnung für mehrere stunden
das war eine person der hätte ich dir
nicht sagen können hey der hat total
viel dreck gerade am stecken was hinter
den kulissen alles abgeht anteil ist ein
total netter sympathischer unfassbar
freundlicher mensch der auch wenn du mit
ihm essen gästen der erste wäre der sagt
hey komm lass stecken die zahl die
scheiße deswegen hätte ich nie mit so
einem video gerechnet und vor allem
nicht damit gerechnet was bei ihm seit
jahren im hintergrund vorgehen genauso
wenig bei kelly kelly jede woche ein
neues video immer lustig drauf netter
mensch wenn man sie persönlich trifft
sondern plötzlich kommt ihr
nervenzusammenbruch video
man weiß nicht was bei den leuten hinter
den kulissen abgeht also das ist punkt
nummer 1 nur weil sich jemand irgendwie
im internet allzu fröhlicher
herausstellt oder heraus gibt oder keine
ahnung was ist passiert immer jeder hat
irgendwie probleme im hintergrund sogar
zwei wenig euch heute mitgeben möchte
ist ganz einfach wenn ihr einnahmen
erzielt rechnet einfach mit der hälfte
rechnet immer mit der hälfte
egal ob youtuber oder selbstständig in
dem anderen in einer anderen branche
oder ob überhaupt nicht selbstständig
mit der hälfte rechnen und man ist auf
der sicheren seite auch fliegen vier
1000 kraniche über müll raus also zum
punkt nummer zwei sind immer mit der
hälfte wenn ihr 10.000 euro verdient
rechnet damit dass sie 5000 euro
ausgeben könnt dann seid ihr immer auf
der sicheren seite und habe keine
nachzahlungen strafen et cetera
mittlerweile das ist in meinem fall
überraschung so dass sich
steuervorauszahlungen tätigen muss das
heißt das finanzamt sagt dann hey für
das kommende jahr 2020 wissen wir doch
hat 2009 so viel verdient und dann sagt
uns jetzt mal die steuern für 2020 es
ist halt so dass wenn man mehr verdient
wenn ende 2020 noch mal was nachzahlen
muss ansteuern und wenn man weniger
verdient bekommt man was zu recht vom
finanzamt sind verstehe ich auch nicht
aber ist halt das gesetz ich habe von so
vielen deutschen youtube an bisher
mitbekommen dass irgendwelche steuer und
wirtschaftsprüfungen hatten unter
anderem jahre und monte beispielsweise
aber ich denke wenn man von beginn an
alles richtig macht und ich weiß auch
ich hatte von beginn an den
steuerberater
andere kleine youtuber gesagt hey das
macht gar keinen sinn nach youtube seit
sechs jahren ich hatte noch keine
prüfung bei der die zahlen sehen und
wissen hey das wird vernünftig und
korrekt alles gemacht und die dritte und
letzte sache die ich euch heute mitgeben
möchte das ganz einfach seid ihr selbst
lasst euch nicht von irgendwelchen
rückschlägen oder irgend welchen scheiß
kommentaren oder irgendetwas anderem
runter bringen lassen er lockt schmeißen
bei anton war es leider der fall dass es
liegen so weit runter gebracht hat dass
er zu drogen gegriffen hat deswegen
leute nach jedem regen kommt licht und
sonne irgendwie so geht das zitat das
habe ich auch bei anton darunter
geschrieben und das war bisher bei jedem
in jedem leben immer so
ich will doch gar nicht mehr lange jetzt
reden ich habe nur dieses video gesehen
von anton und hat es mir wirklich
komplett angeschaut 74 minuten lang und
es war bei mir einfach so ich habe mich
danach gefühlt auch ein video dazu zu
machen
vor allem weil ich dazu kellys video und
zu montevideo die auch millionen aufrufe
haben schon damals mir gesagt haben ich
jetzt nicht meine meinung zu sagen bin
ja eigentlich in 99 prozent der fälle
ein kanal der erträglich sein video
bringt vorher irgendwelche neuen
schwachsinn ausprobiert und so weiter
und so fort allerdings finde ich so auch
manchmal schön einfach meine meinung
deswegen dem thema zu sagen gibt
natürlich jetzt nicht persönlich gegen
anton wenn ich sage hey deine schwester
videos oder caddy da nervenzusammenbruch
video fand ich ein bisschen übertrieben
oder monster ist echt zu blöd und weiß
nicht wie steuern funktionieren das sind
natürlich alles keine persönlichen
angriffe ich mag kelly ich markanten
unfassbar gern sind ganz ganz nette
menschen und monster
ich glaube das ist wirklich ein mensch
der keim was böses tun möchte es gab ja
diese rassismus-vorwürfe und so weiter
und so fort also allgemein gab es ist
ziemlich viel vorwürfe gegen monte aber
ich glaube monster ist wirklich auch
tief im herzen ganz ganz ganz ganz
lieber mensch allerdings hoffe ich euch
hat das heutige video gefallen ich hoffe
ich konnte eventuell dem einen oder
anderen ein bisschen was erklären bzw
näher bringen beziehungsweise auch den
ein oder anderen tipp geben wie man sich
als youtuber verhalten sollte wie man
sich allgemeinen in unserer wirtschaft
mehr oder weniger verhalten sollte ich
habe 50 minuten gerade geredet und die
sonne geht unter
[Applaus]
[Musik]